el cáncer es una enfermedad que no es
crimina entre indígenas africanos
asiáticos o blancos en el mundo existen
43 millones de personas que viven con
esta enfermedad
sin embargo la investigación oncológica
está sesgada hacia poblaciones
caucásicas todo lo que se sabe se ha
hecho a partir de personas de origen
europeo
pero porque es importante estudiar el
carácter desde un punto de vista étnico
pues más o menos hace una década varias
investigaciones demostraron que este
aspecto es bastante importante tenemos
el caso del cáncer de pulmón no se ha
visto que los asiáticos responden mejor
a los fármacos que las personas de
origen caucásico otro ejemplo en cáncer
de colon se ha visto que las personas de
origen africano tienen mayor prevalencia
de este tipo de cáncer existen 50 casos
cada 100.000 habitantes con respecto a
40 casos si analizamos la gente de
origen caucásico
este ejemplo es bastante intrigante
porque los asiáticos y los africanos
tienen mayor toxicidad a la
quimioterapia corrigen con respecto a la
gente de origen blanco
entonces
a qué se debe esto pues dentro de muchos
aspectos uno de los más importantes es
la variabilidad genética cuando se hizo
el estudio de la variabilidad genética a
nivel mundial los puntos negros que
están en el mapa se puede ver que
existen 88 millones de variantes de las
cuales la mayoría son mutaciones de un
solo nucleótido después tenemos
inserciones de lesiones
variantes estructurales si analizamos
estas variantes a nivel más específicos
podemos ver que existen variantes que
están
específicamente en las poblaciones
estudiadas es decir por ejemplo si
estudiamos la población ecuatoriana
seguramente tendremos variantes
genéticas que son sólo de nuestra
población si comparamos con peruanos o
colombianos también hay variantes
específicas de los continentes y si
analizamos por ejemplo el examen exoma
es la parte codificante del genoma es
decir lo que da las proteínas
se encontró que existe una variante cada
ocho bases del exoma el exoma tiene 30
millones de variantes
entonces como les puedo demostrar
nosotros somos bastante genéticamente
variables entonces volviendo a la parte
oncológica les voy a demostrar por qué
es importante estudiar el cáncer con un
enfoque étnico la oncología se divide en
dos aspectos fundamentales la
investigación en oncología tenemos de
investigación
fundamental en la investigación clínica
la investigación fundamental tiene
varios aspectos uno de ellos es la
histología de dónde
estudiamos los tejidos de las personas
que tienen cáncer y podemos dar un
diagnóstico podemos estudiar proteínas
que están más expresadas y así otro
aspecto son los modelos de investigación
ustedes han visto seguramente esas
investigaciones en ratones se usan
líneas celulares que es una línea
celular básicamente es un trozo del
tumor de una persona que se cultiva en
el laboratorio
y en este se descubren muchas cosas con
respecto a esta enfermedad en estas
células es un recurso infinito siempre
están creciendo entonces es algo
bastante importante después tenemos la
genética y la genómica esto digamos
desde el futuro con la genética y la
genómica vamos a poder detectar las
variantes específicas de cada población
y dar una medicina personalizada en base
a toda esta investigación oncológica
fundamental se descubrieron los aspectos
más básicos del cáncer
y con este conocimiento se desarrollaron
medicamentos estos medicamentos
posteriormente se utilizan
para probar en población mediante
investigaciones clínicas
entonces con respecto a este primer
aspecto que es la histopatología
tenemos el ejemplo del cáncer de mama
cuáles son las consecuencias de no
incluir estas poblaciones
pocos representadas entonces en cáncer
de mama es este ejemplo es bastante
bastante llamativo tenemos un marcador
que es el x 67 este marcador se
sobreexpresa en muestras tumorales
ustedes pueden ver en esta imagen un
tejido normal y un tejido tumoral aquí
tenemos cuando más color marrón tienes
mayor expresión a de proteína es
entonces este es un marcador de
agresividad si tú sobre expresas esta
proteína significa que tienes un tumor
más agresivo
pues una investigación demostró
si se compara este marcador entre
poblaciones mujeres de origen árabe con
respecto a mujeres de origen caucásico
este marcador en mujeres de origen árabe
es mucho más elevado pero su progresión
tumoral no es necesariamente más fuerte
entonces tú estás dando un diagnóstico
erróneo porque intrínsecamente esta
población expresa este marcador de mayor
medida pero no tienen una progresión
tumoral igual de fuerte que las personas
caucásicas entonces esto es bastante
importante para poder dar un diagnóstico
adecuado en nuestra población también
otro ejemplo
bueno si analizamos
los biobancos los biobancos son
y repositorios de tejidos que se
utilizan para estudiar este tipo de
cosas cuando analizamos la
representación étnica de estos biobancos
a nivel mundial podemos ver que la
mayoría son de origen caucásico después
tenemos africanos asiáticos o hispanos
continuando con esta investigación
fundamental tenemos los modelos de
investigación en este sentido estas
líneas celulares que les decía
bastante importantes para esta
investigación en 1980 y se generó un
panel de 60 líneas celulares
en estos 60 días celular sé
probaron más de 400 mil compuestos
compuestos que hoy en día se usan para
tratar el cáncer
entonces como pueden ver es bastante
importante este aspecto de la
investigación cuando analizamos el
aspecto étnico de más de 1000 líneas
celulares que existen en la actualidad
la mayoría no se conoce pero de las que
se conocen nuevamente el porcentaje son
de poblaciones caucásicas
otro ejemplo que es lo más importante
que es la genética y la genómica
aquí en el cáncer de piel el melanoma es
un cáncer de piel bastante agresivo que
produce metástasis la metástasis es
lo que al final es lo que te mata son
las células cancerosas que migran a
otros tejidos y causan tumores y tú
mueres
entonces en melanoma en la genómica lo
que se hace es estudiar los diferentes
mutaciones que hay en una población que
tiene este cáncer y tú generas lo que se
denominan subtipos moleculares estos
subtipos guían la clínica de estas
personas es decir guían el tratamiento
si tú tienes de su tipo 1 2 o 4 te dan
un medicamento si tienes un tipo 3 te
dan otro entonces cuando estudiamos la
representación étnica en este cáncer
podemos ver que la mayoría son de origen
caucásico y cuál es el gran problema si
nosotros analizamos la radiación
ultravioleta que es una de las
principales causas del cáncer de piel
podemos ver que los niveles más altos no
están en el norte los estudios estos
están en la línea que inicial donde
nosotros vivimos
entonces la pregunta es tenemos nosotros
esos subtipos tenemos nosotros otras
mutaciones tal vez
tal vez no no se ha investigado todavía
otro aspecto si analizamos esto no sólo
pasa en melanoma esto pasa en todos los
tipos de cáncer
aquí les estoy representando 6 millones
de muestras
y la mayoría son de origen caucásico
todos los subtipos moleculares todas las
cosas que se investigan
resuelto a partir de personas de origen
caucásico
nosotros estamos representados con tan
solo 0.5 por ciento en estos estudios
entonces es algo que tenemos que cambiar
como investigadores en el ecuador
el último aspecto que es la
investigación clínica muestra si
analizamos los tres tipos de cáncer más
grandes que sería
melanoma mama y cáncer de pulmón podemos
ver que la maria de muestras no se saben
cuál es su origen étnico pero de las que
se conoce otra vez el mismo ser personas
de origen europeo
entonces si ahora tomamos todos los
aspectos de investigación geológico
podemos ver este sesgo hacia poblaciones
caucásicas
es decir se investigó en líneas
celulares de personas de origen europeo
para después desarrollar medicamentos
que sólo se usan en personas otra vez de
origen europeo hay medicamentos tal vez
que en el screening original no funcionó
en gente de origen europeo pero tal vez
hubiera funcionado en gente de origen
asiático gente como nosotros gente
ecuatoriana por eso es importante que
nosotros podamos hacer nuestra propia
investigación que podamos crear nuestros
propios modelos nuestros propios
biobancos
entonces este sesgo se ve
más fuerte cuando vemos la población
mundial la mayoría no son caucásicos son
asiáticos tenemos de africanos hispanos
y así entonces qué pasa con el ecuador
justamente un estudio que se publicó
hace dos semanas por nuestro centro de
investigación
muestra que nosotros somos un país
multiétnico compuesto mayoritariamente
de genes indígenas después de europeos y
después africanos como pueden ver
nuestras variantes genéticas tal vez son
mucho más diferentes que lo que se sabe
en la actualidad cuáles son las
perspectivas para nuestro país
justamente algo más mayoritariamente
importante sería la creación de bancos
de tumores porque porque a partir de
estos tejidos podemos hacer histología
estudiar estos marcadores que les
mencionaba podemos crear nuestros
propios modelos de investigación
ecológica con nuestras propias variantes
y no sólo eso podemos también estudiar
nuestros compuestos endémicos de plantas
endémicas tenemos una gran diversidad
tal vez en alguna planta algún compuesto
se encuentra en la cura por el cáncer no
sólo para nuestra población sino a nivel
mundial muchas gracias
[Aplausos]